classes are canceled at at North Georgia
high school this morning after police
arrested a teacher for firing a gun
inside his classroom
Jesse Randall Davidson faces six charges
including making terroristic threats and
aggravated assault
Jericka Duncan is following the
investigation as the nation debates
whether to arm teachers to Rico good
morning good morning
Dalton high school's principal describes
Davidson as an excellent teacher who was
fit to be at work but during yesterday's
incident he says Davidson was behaving
strangely before firing his handgun
around 11:30 Wednesday morning Jesse
Randall Davidson reportedly locked the
door to a social studies classroom and
refused to let anybody in including his
students he slammed the door before I
could open it and said don't come in
here I have a gun principal Steve Barr
too said Davidson was also making
nonsensical noises he ordered Dalton
High School to lockdown it was shortly
after that that I heard a gunshot the
bullet went through a classroom window
nobody was hit but a student twisted her
ankle running away police say the
school's resource officer persuaded the
53 year old teacher to surrender very
very proud of this officer and
everything that he did to render this
horrible situation safe as quick as what
he did
police reports obtained by CBS this
morning showed that in 2016 Davidson
went to police to confess to having
someone killed he also said he was on
several different medications for
depression and was thinking about
hurting himself police could not verify
his claims and sent him to a hospital
and last year Davidson went missing at
school but he was later found wandering
about a mile away
I was scared very scared and Marie
Jacobs daughter Emma a junior at Dalton
sent her these text messages saying an
armed teacher was freaking out yelling
she still agrees with President Trump
that teachers should carry firearms to
help stop school shootings but of course
in return they there needs to be
background checks and just maybe some
evaluations for the teacher the
see if they're stable you know police
and school officials praise teachers for
quickly getting those students out of
harm's way although classes at Dalton
High School have been canceled today
counselors and social workers will be on
hand for any student who needs them and
modestly the kids a lot of them were
shaken up by a very troubling understand
now I think Thank You jurika